hey guys i'm carlos with monte with et
canada how are you doing today hello how
are you
i'm doing well thank you very much you
know uh this being the next adaptation
of a sally rooney novel and with the
success of normal people and the hype
around this series were there nerves
about going in i'm curious about that
for both of you
yeah i think definitely i think i think
there's you know nerves going into to
anything really taking on any kind of
part and but this how it's such a
beloved
book and and sally is such a a
you know adored writer that i think
taking taking on one of her
characters does feel like a a really big
responsibility but also a really big
privilege you know i think her her work
is so loved because it's just so
incredible and and so raw and honest and
and people relate to it so much so i
think just really
you know trying to i guess honor what
she's created and um and kind of step
inside that world is is kind of very
what we tried to do and uh yeah i i hope
we just we did it justice
yeah
joe what did it feel like for you to
take on that responsibility
you know i would second that like of
course there's nerves with anything to a
degree but
first and foremost just being a massive
fan of
sally and her books and also being a big
fan of lenny as a filmmaker and a big
fan of what they did together on normal
people it was just an exciting
opportunity and um like a privilege to
be part of telling a story that
um
meant a lot to me and means a lot to a
lot of people so inevitably nervous but
um but also just like a lot of fun
allison you talked about uh being
paralyzed when you found out
about the role
what was going through your mind when
you actually found out
yeah i actually yeah i mean it was mad
like because it really was i think when
you're auditioning for that stuff like
it's i felt so lucky even to just be
seen by people i admired so much like
you know getting to audition for lenny
and everything was just an incredible
experience and so when i actually got
the job i i genuinely was just so
so shocked and
but yeah it's just it's just that it's
just like a shock and kind of excitement
and
yeah i just i just
was paralyzed
but and and then what then happens when
you start to know who you're going to be
working these scenes with uh you know
the the gentleman besides you the two of
you have some very very intense scenes
so when you know that you're
going to go into those like how do you
prepare yourself
um i don't know i mean i guess i
actually found out joe was doing it
about maybe a week or something after
i'd got cast so we started having chats
really early on like different zooms
with lenny and and i think just you know
getting like being familiar with the
people that you're going to work with
and we had so much time to prepare
before we actually started filming that
like we all knew each other quite well
and and and i think
like lenny creates such a safe
environment and such a wonderful
environment on set that you you just
feel i don't know really kind of able to
do those things with with with him and
and with joe and and sasha and jemima
there was just such a lovely energy that
that it felt really kind of
yeah they they made
it all very easy i think
and the the way it's those scenes are
treated in this show are phenomenal and
they do tell stories uh in themselves
but when you are
watching them with your significant
others is there any sort like do you get
nervous about what their reactions are
going to be
no i mean
we have a screening tonight so my
friends and family and everyone haven't
really seen it yet um so my mind isn't
even kind of in a viewing point of view
um
but
uh
no i don't know i mean
they were handled so well and we work
with an intimacy coordinator who kind of
also work to normal people and
approaches them in such a safe trusting
way and like you said they hopefully
each tell a slightly different story
they're not just there for the sake of
gratuity so hopefully um hopefully yeah
we just did them justice
well thank you so much for the time
congratulations on the series all the
best thank you so much thank you